but I recently saw this movie's Twilight
they are so romantic those vampires
madly in love with this girl and they're
so obsessed with each other they
brainwash you I went into this movie as
I go some movie about high schoolers I
came out and I was like oh my god I have
to marry a vampire oh my god
it makes you obsessed guys don't let
your girlfriend see this movie she will
leave your ass okay after I saw the
movie I wouldn't talk to the guy who was
dating for like five days finally he was
like baby but I was like I don't know I
kind of need to date someone who can fly
but this movie I think it proves that
women have like a bad boy complex cuz
the vampire says to the girl in the
beginning of the movie he's like I want
to kill you I want to suck your blood
she's like it's okay I trust you
and then he admits that he's killed
people before it she's fine with it
which actually I'm such a jealous
girlfriend that if my vampire boyfriend
told me he'd kill people i Blake who was
she
is she prettier than me is that it
[Applause]